[Música]
en un día normal es usual que enfrenta
una serie de imposibles
y no hacer cine no significa una entrada
económica estable no
no puedes realizar a esa idea porque al
patrocinador no le gusta
no no puedes usar esa cámara porque las
mujeres no cargan cosas pesadas así que
tampoco puedes mover esa luz
no puedes montar esa pared no puedes
dirigir a hombres y mucho menos a
mujeres
cada día una serie de imposibles cuando
hacerlo siguen
en honduras ya es una dificultad
y la disparidad de género en la
industria del cine un hecho que debemos
cambiar
éramos tres mujeres sentadas en un salón
de conferencias les explicaba
hasta que salí de honduras hasta que
salí de mi país me di cuenta de las
cosas que como cultura nos hacen
diversos y valiosos
quise regresar a mi país para contar
nuestras historias para contarlas mejor
porque yo misma quiero hacer mejor si
quiero ser parte de un ambiente de
desarrollo
de producciones profesionales
y me miraron
supongo que me catalogaron como ingenua
hacer cine o contar historias con el
medio de arte audiovisual no es fácil
requieren de muchas personas trabajando
en conjunto hacia un mismo fin
yo soy productora así que me involucro
en el desarrollo de un concepto
el desarrollo de modelos de financiación
de realización
también sirve como asistencia para los
demás miembros recursos de información
contabilidad cumplimientos de ley
creatividad logística o en fin
pero en la realización están
los actores y extras la dirección la
edición otros productores la dirección
de foto
arte en sonidos los encargados de
alimentación de transporte de seguridad
y los demás miembros del club o del
equipo de realización
cuando son las dos o tres de la mañana
estas personas son las que con buena
actitud siguen cargando cosas pesadas de
un lado al otro
así que luces rodando sonidos cámaras
acción corten y repetir de nuevo
estos son los esfuerzos que se ven en
los detalles
que quizás
y pasan desapercibidos en pantalla y
todo esto para robarles a ustedes
o a tim un pequeño momento de tu tiempo
es un hecho mensurable que
en las épocas de redes sociales y de
plataformas sociales
preferimos consumir contenido
audiovisual que dure máximo 2 minutos
cuando vemos una película nos
transportamos
a una época abrimos un portal a un
tiempo
y vemos si nos informamos en ese espacio
sobre la cultura las normas las reglas
filosofías de las personas representadas
fantasías como también reflejar
realidades
mi primera cámara
cayó en un río mientras filmaba un
documental sobre en una comunidad
garífuna apenas estaba en secundaria
todo este trabajo se perdió años después
soy premiada por primera vez en mi país
en el primer festival de cine nacional
por un documental sobre mujeres
garífunas toma algo de terquedad de ser
obstinado y obstinada de tenacidad para
realizar lo que deseas para
ejercer en tu pasión cuando los demás te
dicen que no puedes ok
es imposible
en el reciente festival de cine de
cannes
el tema de la disparidad de género o de
la desigualdad de oportunidades para las
mujeres
fue en
el tema resonante y popular
porque para las mujeres
en una industria considerada para
solamente para hombres pues la cuesta
arriba es un poco más difícil
y miembros como la ganadora de oscar a
décadas en miembros del jurado como la
ganadora del oscar ya seca chance en
comentaron que como realizadores a nivel
global nos estamos quedando cortos
porque las películas carecen de una
perspectiva o de una igualdad de género
frente y detrás de la cámara
es que hacer cine o el cine en sí es un
medio de arte pasivo y no violento capaz
de cambiar el mundo
por ser de naturaleza participativo y
que involucra a toda una comunidad y por
ende debe ser inclusivo
soy lester jones crea una comunidad de
mujeres para la realización de su nueva
película desde la directora de fotos
hasta la gripo técnica de iluminación
carpintera ma
y en el proceso se da cuenta que existe
un círculo vicioso
y es que queremos contratar
más mujeres pero suceden
al compararlas con su contraparte
masculina
y descubrimos que no lo que carecen de
experiencia en ciertas áreas
al querer realizar un proyecto a su
mejor en su mejor capacidad optamos por
contratar a las personas con más
experiencia pero esto no conduce a una
solución a largo plazo
directora de arte en su proyecto
jaimes
también explicamos que tal vez a ver me
pase que tal vez algunas mujeres somos
somos
y nos apoyamos entre sí
subconscientemente
de forma subconsciente vale como lo hice
bien porque nuestras probabilidades de
oportunidades de tener éxito en la
industria son mucho menos que la de
nuestra contraparte masculina
estos ciclos conllevan a espacios
inseguros para las mujeres en donde la
desigualdad o la distancia de poderes
crear
creando conflictos de poder
y por ende se dan estos ejemplos de
acoso o abuso sexual como lo hemos
escuchado recientemente en las noticias
sobre la industria en hollywood
en centroamérica no son
29 títulos del largometraje
cada documental y ficción y honduras es
uno de los más productivos y tan solo
cinco de estos de estos títulos de estas
películas son dirigidas por mujeres dato
curioso
estas cinco obras son documentales si lo
traducimos a números o si lo analizamos
con los números de hollywood esto se
traduce a que uno
a que un 34 por ciento de las películas
contaron con solo productores
un 79% contaron con solo editores
y 96% de las películas fueron
fotografiadas por hombres o sea un 4 por
ciento cuatro por ciento por mujeres
si nosotras bueno favor a trasladémonos
a francia en el año 1900 al stewart si
son una de las primeras personas en
experimentar con las técnicas
cinematográficas son una pionera
de la narrativa ficción y de las
técnicas de colonización
y lo peculiar es que cuando nos dan las
clases de historia del cine quienes
destacan como precursores del arte son
su contraparte masculina los hermanos
lumière
a ambos los hermanos lumière y alex
dowsett realizaron obras similares y sin
embargo nuestra herencia histórica sólo
destaca la parte masculina debemos de
dar crédito a las personas según el
crédito que les corresponde
cuando realizaba mi práctica laboral
edite un tributo para años cajal en de
una directora de hollywood
y fue para wilson en washington
y sentí una gran satisfacción al exaltar
a una mujer
la organización está ahí para aportar o
para apoyar a las redes de mujeres para
transformarse en una red de mujeres en
el cine entonces con el objetivo de
apoyar a las mujeres y de crear
oportunidades para nosotras entre
nosotras este año abriremos women in
zion con duras
con el privilegio de desarrollar el cine
en nuestro país como productora todo
esto viene acompañado de ciertas
responsabilidades ya buffer actions es
la primera productora en enfocarse en
multiplataforma y transmitir story time
producimos todo bailaban que fue una de
las primeras producciones hondureñas en
conseguir la coproducción en el marché
du film del festival de cine de cannes a
través del sur son hong kong y fue la
primera producción francesa financiada
con fondos hondureños o sea no al revés
y negras o el documental del cual les
hable m
dirigido y producido por mujeres sobre
mujeres
bolt es el primer concurso
centroamericano que premia el primer
lugar
para una mujer guionista
y el comité seleccionador de honduras
seleccionando la primera obra en toda la
historia que competirá porque esperamos
que compita en los oscars y ahora women
en toma
así que para cada
para cada serie de imposibles una
respuesta artística
en el 2010
a las estadísticas de latinoamérica
según el estudio de mckinsey reveló que
son 30 perdón son 24% de las empresas y
sus ejecutivos que colocan la diversidad
de género entre sus prioridades en
agenda
y en el 2013 fueron 31% más o menos
aproximadamente y está creciendo
cada película es una empresa es como una
empresa tiene su principio de desarrollo
es un momento de manufactura de
producción y cuando alcanza su mejor
momento se vende
con las redes sociales disponibles no
tenemos excusas cambian nuestras formas
de iu nuestros hábitos de información de
interacción
y crear oportunidades significa que
reducimos las injusticias para todos no
solo para un género más que otro
es así que
estaríamos en un mundo donde todos y
todas seríamos mutuamente responsables
considerando que las oportunidades
conducidas hacia la cultura alimentan
nuestro espíritu nuestra inteligencia
nuestra creatividad gracias
[Aplausos]